this line wraps around three times
before it starts going straight if
you've traveled recently you've likely
seen long lines and Stranded passengers
airports will definitely be
significantly busier than summer of
2021. inflation is also pumping up the
price of everything from food to flights
to gas so to help you save money and
time Wall Street Journal travel
columnist Don Gilbertson has three tips
to help you navigate this busy travel
season
number one plan ahead to save time and
alleviate stress at the airport one
option A lot of Flyers don't seem to be
aware of yet is a relatively new program
that allows you to reserve a spot in the
security line for free this program is
offered at several airports including
those in Seattle Los Angeles and Newark
New Jersey each airport has its own
protocols but generally Travelers can
sign up for 15-minute security
appointments up to 72 hours before their
flights once at the airport you show a
QR code and enter designated checkpoint
lanes that take you to the front of the
general security line the Phoenix
Airport for example told me that people
who have used that line on average
report saving at least 20 minutes in the
security checkpoint TSA pre-check and
clear can also save time but they charge
membership fees
another time saving option a relatively
new feature at airport Starbucks
locations you can now do mobile ordering
at the airport and anybody who's seen a
Starbucks line at a major airport or
even a smaller airport you know
sometimes they can rival the lines at
the TSA checkpoint use the Starbucks
mobile app to skip the line and place
your order I place my order at 508 and I
received my coffee at 5 14. and for
those renting cars you can also take
advantage of line skipping options by
signing up for rental agencies loyalty
programs
tip number two if something goes wrong
like your flight gets canceled act
quickly don't just do one thing you know
if you're gonna go get in that line
while you're in that line get on the
airline's mobile app look at other
options at the Airport United Airlines
for example has a new tool called agent
on demand which connects Travelers with
customer service agents in other cities
as a way to speed up the rebooking
process I'm also a very big fan of
reaching out to Airlines on Twitter uh
direct message they tend to get back to
you quicker you start the conversation
about rebooking another thing to keep in
mind is if an airline cancels your
flight and gives you your money back
that refund might not cover the cost of
a new flight this summer do not ask for
that refund you know so that you can
book on another airline until you shop
another airline because that flight
could be three times the price that you
paid so this summer in a lot of cases
you have to weigh the airlines rebooking
option finally shop around if you have
haven't booked your airline tickets yet
maybe check out some of the newer
airlines that have launched uh during
the pandemic a couple that come to mind
are avello and Breeze Airways since not
everybody has heard of them you might
have a better chance at seed
availability both Airlines follow the
model of Discounters like Allegiant and
Frontier
avello operates flights out of New Haven
Los Angeles and Orlando and Breeze
Airways focuses on mid-sized cities like
Hartford Connecticut and Charleston
South Carolina check their websites
because a lot of times uh the tickets
are significantly cheaper both Airlines
have relatively new planes experienced
Executives and some routes you can fly
Non-Stop and skip the connecting airport
drama but keep in mind that these
smaller Airlines might not have as many
flight options on most routes they don't
fly every single day so you know in
times of flight troubles you might not
be able to get out as quickly as you
want if you're going on a road trip you
might be able to save money on gas by
using the same tools you use at home if
you have a Costco membership uh you know
Walmart also has a membership program
you know you can use those savings on
the road uh GasBuddy is one of the apps
that a a lot of people download before a
trip it'll find the lowest gas in your
area but regardless of where or how you
you plan to travel this summer I have a
backup plan maybe a couple backup plans
you know we've all seen the headlines on
the number of canceled flights and
delayed flights so just look at your
options before you take off